why do you get to be Hoops I I'll let
you whomever you want I'll be Max I'm
starting the game are we ready I'm ready
yes I'm even recording God I hope I'm
recording it says I am I see audio I see
I hope it's a nebulous thing of whether
or not uh Wade is in fact recording wait
is always doing Schrodinger's recording
you never knows it's alive or dead until
you open it after the recording session
is already over you're not wrong
in like years until I literally muted
the audio last time and almost didn't
put the game this time I don't know
what's happened well you're getting
older we're getting older we should talk
about that in a podcast we should do a
podcast about that yeah make a podcast
call it distractible
oh maybe I'll put the link in the
description when we make it
what is the sound that I'm hearing and I
don't like it I just want to say that
it's so in my ears really you guys are
playing Antarctica because I can't join
I don't know I'm not in there either
waiting for other players we're waiting
for you Wade how is your internet this
slow what is even this I don't know it
could be all the porn I'm downloading
well we can't have him stop that that's
that's a necessity that's it for sure
it's for it's important uh online work
real Hands-On kind of stuff load game
load
[Laughter]
this icon just went there Wade finally
got here oh hey I'm watching He-Man on
TV look copyrighted material oh you
don't know that it's yoked
[Laughter]
I love what yoga girth talks to the kids
apricot
holy crap
really hard glizzies oh hell yeah oh my
God
hello when did the term glizzies become
a thing no idea and I hate it what is
that oh okay it means hot dogs but it's
just gross sounding
those teens look like us
stranger grounded
Oh
I thought the music was kind of strange
how to pay attention to the story
oh we're missing
all right I guess that is the whole
story what kind of teenagers are eating
this [ __ ] an ant oh three oh my God
don't give me garbage
God they're multiplying Market it's
Mark's house
what happened was I threw away some
strawberries and then I came back and it
was a nightmare it was so many ants oh
no it was just don't waste strawberries
lesson learned all right you right
where more can I get more of your wisdom
uh distractible
is sponsored by distractible we're
paying ourselves to be here we're not
there's a little heavy-handed guys
oh no one else is heavy-handed ourselves
to be here the way we Broach topics on
world-renowned podcasts distractible ah
I thought you were gonna see all the
music that I turned down to 20 percent
what you talking about
no no no no
I'm blind did anyone else get hit by a
parachute yes
we reached the crescendo of
man one of my music's at 20 volume oh
god what happened oh God
oh my god oh I'm so wobbly there we go
oh
Max you're
do I have inverted controls no no it's
controlling it's okay now we're good
okay hi oh we were in human shaped foam
cutouts I love that part this hole was
made for me wait why are there five
there's five look how jumpy I am four of
us can play and one of us is the traitor
who's out there somewhere one of us is
already dead what is making that no I'm
gonna squash a goddamn bug it's a bug
bug well it didn't shut up there I'll
tell it in text
forgot our voice activation was off this
whole time
wow God it's been years I've been years
yeah we've played This Way in the hell
this is not how it started before no
this is the I remember we're living did
we live on a baseball yeah we lived on a
base yeah something like that yeah
something like that hey look a baseball
where guys we've got as far as we did
back then this must be where we should
live
I can hook this
oh what the [ __ ]
sorry my health no that hooked hard guys
you could swap between first person and
not first person what
yeah you
some sort of I don't like it Markiplier
discovered sap I don't know if you get
credit for that I'm pretty sure I
discovered it
guys I discovered uh there's ants over
here ants are bad right
uh I think they're no you know what yeah
I remember I have no idea
I remember I know nothing whoa there's a
live wire we can shock ourselves
Jon Hamm isn't real John Hamm can't hurt
me Jon hammers on him can't hurt me why
are you so afraid of Jon Hamm yeah
what's up with Jonah why aren't you what
did Jon Hamm do to you uh well nothing
yet
because he's not real so he can't hurt
me uh
they're making puns about weevils guys
how I feel about this I saw I could turn
that off I guess
hey I discovered a field station honey
like that I'm on a tripod how do you
like that
I fell off I've done nothing of value
how do you like that we don't I don't
like that whoa who got the raw science
who's out sciencing sciencing the hell
out of this guy oh my God put on some
science protection before you go at it
like that
ah keep falling all right guys damn I'm
more science coming in hot I might give
up I might give up guys guys I might eat
to give up yeah I think where are you
don't give up gonna give up you need to
call me I'm eating I'm eating to give
Ike no hold on but not for long I had 20
seconds until I E to give up don't worry
Mark I can't one of us will save you
probably
no choice
what's your name Max Max Max I'm here my
good buddy whose name I will never
forget Thanks Max I'm here too friend
thanks oh no oh
ow ow God don't hurt our friend who did
that Max oh sweet Lord It's a lawn mine
yeah they're on this uh cable let's see
if I fall and die again
oh [ __ ] oh guys guys kiss me
I thought he was attacking you
[Applause]
straight up help help us
help help take this help yeah the ants
don't attack you until you attack them
this way
that's not true I did it hated Bob it
had an I hate Bob's Pizza stand up Max I
gotta hold it thanks Peter come on come
on I had you hi I'm paying you back for
that one man I'm definitely accepting
your payback payment what do I owe you
uh it's like a crisp high five all right
I'll try
oh God sorry sorry I thought we were
gonna do it at the same time
oh frick
we have a lot of extra L for fun all
right good good all right should we uh
analyze a pebblet at a resource analyzer
guys
we have missions
in the top left oh we do where's a
resource analyzer I done found it
already it's over where the yellow
exclamation point is oh you yeah that we
should have been paying attention I
suppose probably don't worry guys I
killed the ant guys I'm doing it no
worries I analyze the pebble it never
seen a man raw dog science like you do
before did you just do the science thing
or was that in the game what I didn't do
anything I just analyzed something and
the game was like solids yeah I saw I
saw that you heard that I didn't hear
that did you do that I hear literally
the game that's the sound it made not
like oh it it was impressed with my
science it was for you it made the sound
wow I mean that's pretty cool man uh can
I do some science uh no probably not
echoey uh I can make a pebble at ax now
ooh that sounds pretty good so that's
pretty cool
where's the guys don't worry I'm back
hi welcome back I made it I killed Nat
and I got red ant Parts guys I got an ax
I'm gonna analyze something
what happens if I hit Mark with my ex
analyzing I'm analyzing a nose
[Music]
yeah so it did something Goofy for you
too yeah that's pretty fun that's pretty
fun I'm not gonna lie that's okay that's
very fun curious
oh we're out of battery
ah we need power okay I see don't worry
guys I got this you equipped I want you
to go away I don't unequip you X
with grass
wait I saw you trying to hit stop
this it's a peaceful world
oh God I didn't mean I owed you one
start this you've already got it sap uh
yeah I had one you need it you couldn't
hear her take for my abuse of you take
uh take wait where'd they go wait where
are they is there a quick button for
crafting versus I then craft I do not no
here do you have if you have plant fiber
Mark you can make a sap and fiber into a
bandage oh band did you say I could make
mushrooms slurry
C is craft wood C C thank you
I need two rocks and I can make a hammer
which I think is what we need to build
how can I already make a gas mask and
the clothings man you got some you got
some stuff fast dude I got so much
science you didn't even know I'm just
gonna make uh Spear and a sprig I could
make a roasting oh I need dry grass for
that I make ax I guess I have X sweet I
already did
well I mean that's great it doesn't I
already did I mean I'm proud of you God
why does it hurt you should be proud of
me because I did it already yeah yes
you're so violent and difficult feels
good to chop grass I can't hold any more
big grasses oh yeah when we start
stockpiling this yeah where we want to
live on a baseball somewhere else uh is
somewhere baseball is here in baseball
baseball
same old say the more we change but we
don't have to we were you're right we
don't we could literally go anywhere
he's really impressionable right now Bob
can you go impressionize him
uh I am pretty impressionable it's true
no you're not no I'm not I'm My Own man
why don't you guys uh follow me uh yeah
follow me up to this hill hey you guys
thirsty I'm thirsty yeah I'm getting
there
yum never mind let's follow Mark all
right okay all right it's gonna be like
a clearing over here right some kind of
clearing
um there's something right ahead yeah
what is this what is this over here
we're gonna eat for days oh yeah we
probably should find a fresh water
source and build a camp by that right
yeah I'm thirsty water's a good idea I
see that there's water potentially 11
centimeters away towards a yellow here
thingy is this water this is water this
is water is it fresh it's clean and safe
probably not I'm unloading yuck well
slurp nasty water oh well I'll try it
I don't want to understate this but this
whoa is bad no it makes your food go
down oh no you don't want to drink that
oh God all right I'm gonna not all right
we're gonna reload on grass wait don't
drink easy with the kicking easy with
the kicking around there chance I wasn't
kicking I swear easy easy water
what basketball I think that would be a
lot here's more water but it looks also
nasty hey there's a leaf over here oh
there's an ant over here hmm wait this
doesn't look as bad no that's just as
bad never mind I don't don't listen to
me I'm an idiot I remember like in the
mornings there's Dew that we can get off
the leaves but I don't know what we do
about getting drinks right now yeah
isn't there like a pond or something
yeah somewhere is there a map hey a map
hey the pond is oh man Southwest are you
sure that's the map or the pond I mean
it's Blue pond is north
oh yeah look at the North that's cleaner
yeah all right which way is North uh
can we like Mark the map or something
yeah
Waypoint Waypoint I don't yeah my do you
see my Waypoint yeah why do I have a a
water marker on my I do see that oh no
it's dude oh it's a dew drops
real quick well I think one of us can
get that real quick thanks
yeah it didn't drink it it bounced off
of me
[Music]
well
time to drink some poo I'm going to the
lake because I want to see that all
right I'm gonna go I'm gonna go to my
Waypoint I'm with Mark wow I found
nothing guys
man it's boring over here why is it so
bouncy oh
um
yeah you get that dude
delicious dude thank you yeah yeah
there's more dude right here I need it
so bad I'm so jealous I wish I had that
oh hey what's up man oh nothing oh were
you marveling over the juice box yeah
just wishing there was something in
there
oh okay hey there usually is that would
have been really cool if there was man
I imagine there probably was and someone
maybe drink it I feel like we're not
going towards my Waypoint Mark where's
your well you have a waypoint to the
left oh hey Waypoint oh Waypoint oh no
very impressionable Mark spiders what
spiders
to go to the right of where we are huh I
don't see any spiders oh good okay then
that's fine spiders oh you found it oh
my God
I'm out of standing uh
oh no I'm dead to us no no no no you're
not dead you're not dead not to me
okay where are you how did you even get
up there oh Logan are you hey oh man it
needs to leave it's just there oh I'm on
some ground don't worry okay all right
okay wait I think you could do me now
I'm stuck wait wait come here yeah I'm
working on come here Wade I got 10
seconds buddy I'm here what about me I
can't do it I got 10 seconds for either
of you buddy
Mark do you see the woobly wobbly
grasses yeah I see a spider too get the
things take the stuff run away Mark
you're so dead I'm so dead well we got
the collective are dead well guys I'll
see you oh oh rescue rescue whoa
oh guys I'm thinking we're in a place
we're not so hey wait can you help oh
yeah sure oh he was gone he's backing
away he's backing away
run
I got grass for some reason running
throw it oh hey Mark hello how's it
going uh hey did we get to your marker
no
not oh it's a baby spider yeah those
those are still bad those are so bad or
Weaver Jr
I can't hug there we go oh God who did
that wait did you do that no I would
never I uh don't worry Mark we're safe
here good good oh foreign
are we just respawning yeah yes
oh it's a science center oh hey my
backpack is over there in Hell
well maybe I'll just not a science
center I spawned in a creepy pit oh what
was that you know what guys I Like It
where we are I like the baseball you
know it's good do I'm good with do I
like what's nice I think we should build
a fort over not there by the place yeah
I agree I also realized I kind of like
uh third person because I resurrected in
third person and it was kind of nice so
I'm gonna go third person now I thought
you didn't like it well now I do things
change Man look
babe don't worry about it there's this
hold your ant over here um got my bag
you went all the way over how did you
get your bag it's not that far it's we
ran in a big circle like idiots it's
like a 10 second walk away from where we
spawn it really is oh God mine's lost
forever I'd never get it so no I'm
pretty sure it's over there like 10 feet
away no no hey Mark we're back to you
already oh that's it I gathered about as
much as I had anyway so are we gonna
like build a structure or something yeah
I'm gathering up uh stuff I like how
this dude is eating a raw mushroom which
is like a totally normal action to do
like you eat mushrooms on salads and
stuff he's all oh choke down this
mushroom oh I mean I'm the same I can't
do mushrooms I can't do it they're not
like poisonous yeah but I don't like
them if I don't like it kind of have to
choke it down a bit yeah either eat this
or die
it wait where are we living at baseball
or somewhere else I don't know but it's
getting dark I haven't seen baseball
where am that it's huge where we started
yeah it was right I don't why would I
know where that is you didn't see it on
the way out of the case
no
I think I was like hey here's the
baseball and Barbara's like yeah that's
the baseball yeah I heard that and I was
like man where's the baseball
you want to see the baseball you I'm at
the case maybe no the not that case the
case where we first spawned in like
where the five people slots were oh I
have no idea where that is I guess I'll
die how are you guys so far away from me
what's happening here I'm not that far
I'm right next we're not that far is
this close oh hey Jesus yeah this is
where I'd like to stay this close I
guess together we'll go find Mark who's
very far away hello how will we ever
find him
Mark where are you I don't know
Mark hello
I can't see you from here in this game
right we don't worry about it getting
dark what what is happening
you put us all into photos
weird all right how who's hitting me I
just I wasn't even facing you I was too
chopping down a thing over here hey that
base thing maybe we should get going on
that right hold on hold on I mean yeah
no no worries probably not it don't
matter is this where we setting up
apparently right here this is it I did
it all right this is it you heard the
man oh we need dry grass chunks I have
dry grass chunks what do you need them
for no no no no no you can't have gotten
them that's where the spiders are
uh hey I found dry grass right next to
us look no right dry grass chunks what
do you need you're Delirious from shrink
Madness I'm Delirious from shrinkage but
I still found some dry grass juice
shrinking by the second were you trying
to make a roasting spit yeah it was just
for us to start cooking up a storm you
know ah yeah
nice how do I get Springs guys
where do I where do I get sprigs sprigs
what's a sprig uh oh I got sprigs never
mind it's a bed spring I'm building a
roasting pit oh never mind I don't I
don't think you're in the window if you
could just wait if you could oh sorry I
couldn't hear you I was too busy being
in your way
I built it
Whoa man what do we do what what the
where are the Clover there's a clover
shut up you
get dead
wow guys I'm cooking something nice oh
that's so we're so sad to look at that
it's kind of messed up it's kind of
messed oh god what happened is this ant
Angry or no no it's just curious It's
just chilling we're cooking food and
it's like well I like food hold on I'm
gonna build my lean too and then we're
gonna be uh oh three peens like some
number of beans and some type of module
uh remember the good old days when we
did a podcast on Twitch yeah I wish we
would have brought that back somehow
maybe on official podcasting platforms
yeah maybe keep it free to listen to
everywhere so it's not hard I really I
really do wonder how many people are on
Twitch just like waiting for the day
like they'll come back they'll come back
they're still just sitting on the page
yeah it's just like whoa I keep
refreshing in the hopes no this little
page it was just our Pages wasn't it
streamed separately together wow what
amateurs we were back then idiots idiots
man I'm a nerd we're gonna be so I just
got my torch out and my character was
like
yeah you you
watch out watch out pop watch out watch
out there's a Madman swinging in the
next Right Where You Are
oh I'm fine you're fine
do you like our Trail marker for home I
like it it's good die
we've crafted a fiber bandage that's so
cool wait this worker has told something
what did he have no little bag in its
mouth oh they're cool they're cool no
the other one had a bag in its mouth I
was carrying a loop oh hey I should cook
some food I'm kind of getting hungry man
somebody like eat my Weevil that I
killed and cooked for my I think an ant
ate it I did not know that that could
happen that's why they're here we're
cooking we're cooking stuff up and
they're like hey the I like that stuff
I'm investigating the machine guys I
guess hey why stop I don't know because
it says to stop doing it stop doing that
okay don't yes keep going
no or don't oh there's the guy with the
bag hey why do you have a bag we could
kill him and take it don't why would you
do that hey we could kill him and take
it oh no that's an idea how do you tell
when it's done cooking with it says
roast instead of raw why does it say Raw
now it says roast now it's done it says
Weevil roast
science
that's an analyzer God at least I'm not
a nerd about it like you do we have to
progress a bit before we um unlock like
walls and stuff
in the top left we're supposed to do
those things it says then we get more
stuff preempt if I have a bandage okay
what did you just say I agree
I thought you're right did you use all
of our charges mark it was empty when I
got there how are you doing science oh I
just like saying that out loud to myself
oh yeah I can get that mistake okay make
that mistake and it would be your
mistake to make I guess that's a
trustworthy boss
who dropped glass on my house
what's happening I don't I don't like it
I don't know boss but I like it
what is happening why why is this grass
I don't know again
why are you having so much trouble
the grass is rooting my house oh okay
sleep through the night is our Quest you
guys want to sleep through the night oh
sure yeah snooze I'm ready to eat my
pillow I'm so tired I'm ready to eat my
pillow I'm so tired as soon as this
meat's done cooking I will hop in oh I'm
ready to eat my pillow I'm so tired yeah
excellent yeah yeah yep I'm ready to eat
my pillow I'm so tired yep
a little feeling a little low energy I'm
ready to eat my pillow I'm so tired
[Laughter]
[Music]
dramatic daytime this game is so fake
what kid wakes up at six a.m none I mean
I guess you're right investigate the
mysterious machine
you're the machine oh man this machine
is hanging right out there yeah the
machine oh I need to hire I don't see
anything that mysterious I don't know I
don't know what it wants
you guys see this cassette tape up here
wait Weevil on top of the the anal bead
machine
I don't think that's what it is but I'm
a kid so what do I know uh well clearly
your parents weren't as cool as mine
what did you burn thank you everything
okay
I mean I am speaking to you from the
backyard
I am tiny I should gather my thoughts
this is a momentous occasion
well totally official log 89.08.05
my first steps into the miniature world
its sights are unbelievable
patterns in all of the objects that
surround me the grass even common lawn
grass looks like a structure from an
alien world
wait
what's that sound
every Earth is trembling
over there what could it be
an ant
my God today the world has changed
well I can't even underwater apparently
so well that was interesting we need to
build a workbench analyze a grass plank
at a resource analyzer I know how to do
that whoa he knows how to do that oh
guys just wait I can't do a work bench
how can you do a workbench I can't I
think we have to analyze the grass plank
first oh never mind I'm analyzing that's
not the way hey wait hey which way is
the Science Guy
well bill here it is found it nope
that's not the way it's this way where's
science Mark where's science it gets in
the thing with the thing how can you not
find it it
take that aphid I wish we had a compass
is there a compass anywhere maybe we
could craft a compass later but if you
look at your map you see the gooching of
radio signals bursting out of your head
that shows where you're pointed I know
but I have to like open the map turn
open the map that's why we're making
landmarks we've got our home and
eventually we'll expand it I like it I
don't like it I know what you're saying
yeah look we didn't get a compass in
raft until way later yeah the raft is
like 10 feet wide all right that's fair
okay I found the baseball
what the baseball
whoa that's so many things we should
analyzed grass so long ago
I'm here with some grass and a lot [ __ ]
all right I'm going back
and uh we're gonna build up a storm at
our house yes
of course hey that got us some stuff
look at that what I did nice that's
pretty neat fuzz wait Bob where are you
chose you're in the dirt oh no that's
your that's all that's just your
Waypoint God you should go to that it's
probably safe
how does that work we only analyze so
much per day yeah it's got power it
needs to regenerate man I don't have a
lot of stuff here I brought you some
stuff you're welcome don't spend it all
in my place all right I'll try not to
you and do you oh I just threw my ax
no
where'd it go
I have another one I don't know what
happened but I found another one on the
ground here at some point I think that's
the one I threw before
[Music]
uh yeah I think so there's a clearing
here you could probably build or we
could build it on that science thing oh
can we I mean could we maybe can we oh
invalid surface
that sounds stupid all right well
obviously we need a raised platform
first obviously obviously so we need
like is there like any kind of uh
staircase or something like that well we
do unlock more stuff when we actually
investigate the machine so maybe at that
point it doesn't look like there's a
staircase yet
well who wants to be in the foreman of
this construction not it I'll do it
that's it all right what exactly do you
need me to do I don't know set down the
blueprints and will gather the supplies
and put them it'll do it all right it's
Bob I'm ready we're gonna hang on I'm
ready
wait I'm so ready I need acorns keep
waiting oh God I'm ready
this is gonna be the science corner
we can already make these things oh we
can make a shovel and a bow and arrows
oh that sounds I could do that without
this
oh shush okay you can make an eye patch
yeah an iPad could make a canteen to get
some Wawa you want to get grubs and
acorns which are by the tree wherever
the big tree is yeah let's buy the lake
where the spiders is well it's early
enough in the day I'm risking it boys
okay bye bye acorns and grubs here I
come all right you do that uh Bob would
you like me to go in a suicidal
Direction yes please uh Which Way guys I
made a storage basket look oh what do we
put in it anything oh wait don't we have
to go to the um the tree anyway in order
to do the machine oh I have a raw Weevil
meat I should cook it what we need to do
is investigate the mysterious machine
which is south of us okay
that sounds like work did you guys know
a hammer is not a chopping tool
no you know I heard that something oh
there goes my ax again I just threw it
how are you even doing that man it just
happens I don't know why what am I
supposed to investigate about this thing
we all need to investigate it together a
mysterious machine I think yeah I think
it's this wait how did you make the
thingy play
I just grabbed a tape that was sitting
on top of it uh this ant is really
staring down all this food I'm cooking
yeah I'm pretty sure they stole Bob's
earlier they just stole my food it just
stole my food oh hey I investigated the
machine I just pushed the button those
lasers I made a quad flame and it just
keeps eating my meat
[Laughter]
this is why we need
all need to be here
is all about
uh why can't I craft this Markiplier
discovered gnat roast yeah that's it
that's what I did oh hell yeah oh it
looks sick God it looks sick I've got
armors yeah oh you investigated the
machine apparently so yeah I pushed the
button oh I need to set my respawn to my
lean too no no something is happening
with the lasers yeah we gotta fix them
and then that does something oh okay
I'll go to that tripod that is pointing
to you that way I was trying to do that
before but I think that was the one I
was falling off and dying from well we
got to go to the one that's been all
zippity's Deputy right yeah I'm there
you're there no you're not yeah I am
wait Zippity zappy there's there's a
laser shooting up off the machine that's
all flickery oh you gotta go investigate
that oh as if that was the weak one I
see I see I see I went to the strong one
you fool I know sorry
you oh God oh God there's a bunch of
douchebags over here
hey we're in your wigs with douchebags
we're only here because we're douchebags
okay I fixed one of the broken lasers oh
cool what'd you do I cut down grass that
was blocking it cool one to go not my
problem
everything okay
oh no it's not oh
doing that thing you did Mark
dying falling off of a high place ah
yeah that'll get you every time yeah
trick is to not do that thing and
actually do the opposite complicated
yeah pretty tough takes a while to get
good at it uh it's a spider that's his
eyes are glowing I am running [ __ ] I'm
gonna die how did I get up here to the
freaking oh no no
no we're all individually doing stuff
that's gonna kill us no no no no yes yes
how am I supposed to climb that then oh
my God where am I
I'm gonna stomp on it
you tell them Hoops yeah you tell them
Hoops guys I'm so high up right now I
don't feel comfortable I am in spider
town
oh my god oh it's beautiful though the
lake is actually finished I remember the
last time we were here there was nothing
here
is Gorge
oh private grabs I haven't grabbed plant
fiber yeah what am I doing with my life
you fool oh my God mosquitoes oh that
one's engorged with blood how did you
get that blood no it ain't one of us now
it'll leave me oh no guys I could have
died probably did you
uh not yet but probably
did are you
oh I found the acorn area that's where I
am oh you're here where are you yeah I
don't see you I made a shovel and I'm
getting grubbed so we can make canteens
if you see dirt moving let me know
oh is that grub grub is moving dirt yeah
you have to get a shovel order to get
the grub you have to dig them out holy
crap you guys do a lot of damage I'm
whacking them oh my God they can jump
any distance they spy oh it's an ant
thank God
the ant is helping me oh cool that's a
nice ant yeah Mark there's a spider in
your direction yeah I see deep in there
I see I see I see yeah there's not much
grass for it to move but I do see oh hey
oh something just fell and died why
why did you hear that it just fell and
died in front of me
guys I did it nice what'd you do killed
some mites hell yeah also that fixed the
laser we're Whispering because we're in
spider Town yeah it's very scary over
here very sketch
very sketchy hey Mark how's it going I'm
busting up some acorns why are you
talking like that
uh I don't know
Russian what's that answer to it don't
stop done deal
God he's so impressionable you see any
dirt moving no uh not at all I see a
ladybug that's almost like the same
thing Bob what do we need investigate
machine further okay I I you were trying
to get Acorn dirt third alert Acorn
[ __ ] and whatever you can from over
there is basically what we need okay
getting as many air corn bits as
possible my inventory is full but I
don't need plant Fiverr that's for sure
can I eat this I'm consuming this where
is this dirt so buy me but I don't I
don't know on the ground I looked away
it's gone it was here but it's not I
need to eat raw [ __ ]
why won't you eat the acorn bits no no
no raw [ __ ] that's all therefore is
eating oh God I feel sick and you're
leaving all the good Acorn Parts behind
what what happened what do you mean
where how I just grabbed like three no
three I mean one all right you missed
one little chunk no who's hiding you
missed a chunk over here what are you
you stupid no that has to be yours well
yeah it's mine now
oh
my God what is wrong with us what's
happening I don't know why you're hiding
from the spiders and it's driving it's
mad oh he's gun spider crazy I've lost
so much health from eating random crap
did you just break all okay you're a
grab I was like did you break that and
you're leaving all of it don't judge me
you go over there I'll I'll do my thing
I'm looking for dirt whoa what is that
whoa I'm near a science lab
oh hey we found the thing to investigate
further Bob oh God that's not it God oh
never mind we were ahead of the game God
it's spider town in there yeah I don't
think we want to go in there quite yet
it looks they look so scary are they
grabbing all the grubs yeah they might
be grub grub dirt moving dirt dirt right
on my location I'm here on my six it was
right there it moved oh you got it I did
hold on don't worry guys I'm hunting
food for everyone all right I've got one
canteen's worth of grub that is not very
much it takes a while okay have I seen
all the moving dirt and you haven't
you wanna know why it's because I'm in
third person mode oh you know
it does does oh Mark there's mushrooms
over here if you need more food uh I
have plenty of acorn bits I just prefer
to eat the raw meat that's uh in my
inventory gross
[ __ ] don't try to knock it till you
attack all right why'd you leave that
whole Acorn there what do you mean I am
impressed
the whole Acorn uh Wade the sun's going
down we should get back home but the
grub we're 400 meters from home
centimeters you're right
it's the metric system that is also true
not only is he impressionable he's so
right he's so knowledgeable and
impressionable God
how do you know no do what's a good one
word for impressionable how do you know
sucks so much
oh well you see it from the lack of
sucking that I know sucks so much I do
see
all right I'm coming back home Bob 200
centimeters away you're already halfway
there yeah number 400. whoa the thing is
we're there wait I I started running the
moment I said we should get home oh I
didn't want to be over there when it was
dark because that's what this man don't
wait for confirmation so I should
probably get back yeah maybe but you
need to make a torch for like the main
mission oh I did I didn't and I went
away you made it Bob that's all we
needed to know oh okay excellent yeah
then charge apparently
I'm back home Bob what do we need what
do we need I've got some food I need to
cook uh I don't know I need to analyze
Mark we should analyze if we have to
analyze oh yeah analyze Mark I'm at the
annual place come to me at the anal yeah
to me I'm
I'm coming what do you need what do you
need you need something
no do like acorns and stuff all right
again
you know other things sure sure last
time I did this I met volley I'll only
do one oh there's only one power left oh
I might have been analyzing I'll do
Acorn shell analyzing
and storage chest water container
grinder that was a good one grinder hell
yeah God that's so crazy dude that's
nuts
oh yeah I get it hey there's another
Power Wade if you wanna no he's too far
away do you have any other Acorn stuff
too yeah I got Acorn top let's see if
it's just as cool
sap catcher
smoothie station
things are coming through oh my God
those Acorn bits are the best acorns are
dope dude acorns are just made one I
need one what oh my God I'm gonna have
enough for all of us to have canteens
ooh well you better get back Sun's going
down I'm coming back I've got all the
hides he's got all the hides we're gonna
get canteen
but we don't have we've only got
diarrhea water to put in there so oh in
the morning we can fill it with Dew that
was the anal
so good I made wood pallets for the
grass oh nice nice nice
there are maximum amount for these plank
pallets I don't know
I don't know this is super cool nope
that way
we found it it's eating
there we go seems cruel I've got all the
food I'm just picking it up so these
ants don't come eat it like a little
little douche bags yeah that is exactly
what I'm battling with they just come
and steal my food look how many planks
we got yeah yeah boys we're doing it
we're thriving yes and I'll make
canteens as soon as this food is cool
yeah
um
foreign
oh my gosh you guys look at my cool hat
never mind
where'd it go what are you doing nerd
where's your hat if you don't even know
there it is I'm gonna drop your canteens
right here come get a canteen oh canteen
look at my cool hat while you're doing
it whoa oh can't ah it's my bed huh all
right well got it thank you yeah thank
you friend of course friend and you want
this together hat anyone yeah oh what do
you need huh what do you want my hat
anyone yeah hat I got a cool hat oh hat
where oh where you're running away so
it's hard to look at your hat yeah
what's up well I didn't think anyone was
interested it's in the dark I literally
see is it cool it's like a is that an
ant
yeah it's an ant part hey food
all right you guys want it back you guys
want to investigate this machine further
should we do should we sleep first oh
okay
I don't know about the rest of you but
I'm beat oh I don't know about the rest
of you but I'm scared he's too scared to
say anything all right
follows across the land oh God
oh God this is much worse she's worse
what have we done oh no I love this
horror I need a torture oh God
I have no room in inventory for torch I
do have what happened
what happened what happened
okay uh crafting equipment
what you got now yeah what you what do
you got now Shadows so what happens if I
put food
in a basket in a basket uh maybe ants
can get it I don't know does it keep it
safe keep it secret
safe why does the do always form where
there's gross water and then fall in
that's sad yeah there's a lot of dew
there but yeah it is hard to get but I
think if you knock that the grass it's
on down it'll fall
yeah but it keeps falling into the
growth water oh well grab it before it
does that can you climb up there and
drink it oh it
rolled away ah I'm trying to put it in
my you can scoop with your canteen to
fill up your canteen oh yeah
hell yeah this canteen's great thank you
so much for making it all it took was
grubs
all canteen's full you can only do two
all right fine this canteen's not that
great analyzing
juice juice
wow dude nice thanks I should have eaten
my aphid well a for aphid A for effort
didn't really work it was a terrible pun
and I should go die to spiders for it a
for a for I would have accepted that I
already accepted it without even
thinking that was fine I don't know why
you're being so hard on yourself I don't
know
I'm impressionable I trust you this
reminds me of how hard you can be on
yourself when we're recording episodes
of our hit podcast
distractible ah where could people find
that I would love to hear about that
it's very available highly available in
online locations such as Spotify
uh Amazon podcast audible what's that
called probably yeah these such like
places and as well man it's got to be so
incredibly expensive to listen to this
it's free you might think okay well I
was okay oh also how do you know that I
would like this if I'm listening to this
episode of us I'm telling you was
literally every human being who has
listened to this amazing podcast has
ended up liking it as much or more than
even their own children it's a
scientific fact really oh my God I can't
question that it's science you can't no
one can question it it's science once
it's proved to be science you cannot
question change or or further research
it research it in any way whatsoever as
far as I'm concerned that's how science
work and I will not look any deeper into
it ah where but where could I find this
podcast besides the platforms
if I I want to go how go just go on
phone go to podcast just search podcasts
even just type in distractible it's so
popular you'll find it or and also
distractiblepodcast.com is a location
where probably you can find it too also
oh that was so much information I'm so
lazy I'll never get it oh wait maybe
there's a link in the description into
this video what can you do with a big
snail shell probably use it to amplify
when you're listening to distractible oh
[ __ ]
distractible
wow you did it I'm trying to get fuzz oh
uh manscape isn't the right product for
that
uh Rogan Rogaine that's it Rogan jokes
what Oh I thought it was oh my God I
thought I was just advancing the okay
well you're not here for this oh what in
the hell are you doing I pushed one
button
foreign
[Music]